dumb [ __ ] what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another game of thorns
season 8 plot league breakdown video
today I will be taking a closer look at
the so called leak for episode 4 and I
will give my opinions on what I think is
real or fake or at the very least
possible this is another long episode
with a lot of details so let's get
started right away
this one begins with the aftermath at
Winterfell the night king caused an
heiress and Jon to flee the north and
now the night king and his army are
inside of the castle walls the first
thing the night king does is go to the
godswood where the weirwood tree is now
burnt according to this leak the night
King torched the godswood as soon as he
entered the battle and I'm not so sure
if this makes perfect sense or not I
believe the night king is tapping into a
very similar power sources brand stark
the night king was created by the
children of the forest annie was
actually tied to the weirwood tree when
they shoved the dragon glass into his
heart the night king might be using the
weirwood trees just like brian we have
seen the night king physically interact
with bran inside of the weirwood net so
I'm not so sure the night king would
want to destroy these trees I guess you
could make the argument that the night
king could kill the trees to diminish
brains powers but it might diminish his
own powers as well since Brian Stark in
the night King both got their powers to
the children of the forest and the
weirwood net it might not be a good idea
to destroy that system but this is just
a guess or a theory I suppose in my
opinion I don't think the night king
will want to do this there are weirwood
trees beyond the wall and there's no
evidence of the night king or any of the
others trying to destroy them the only
person who is currently concerned about
the where woods is Melisandre she is
actively trying to rid Westeros of the
old gods Melisandre has had trees burned
on a few different occasions in the
books but I don't think that I came well
like I said I think the night king uses
them just as much as bran does the only
thing is we don't see the night king
using them except that one time he
entered brains vision this leak also
says the night King enters the crypts of
Winterfell when he seems to know exactly
where he's going once he's inside as if
he's been there before
I think this would relate to what I said
in the last video that I king is a stark
and he grew up in Winterfell so he would
definitely know his way around the
castle
especially the crypts considering they
were built before most of the castle was
built a lot of what we see today was
added later but the crypts in the broken
tower have been there since the
beginning I have to be honest with you
though I think almost all of this
episode is wrong I know I'm kinda alone
with this theory but I have to stick to
my guns I don't think the knight King
makes it past two Winterfell alive I
know many people believe he will make it
to King's Landing or even the gods I but
I do not this great war will end at
Winterfell right where the story began
it's the location we are most familiar
with and it's the Starks home it's John
and brains home and it's the knight
Kings home they all have stark blood and
this is where it must end this is why a
stark must always remain in Winterfell
because someone from a very long time
ago knew this day would come and as long
as the stark remains in Winterfell the
night King will not be able to take over
their castle I know the gods I theory is
a cool theory but it doesn't make any
sense for the show that location was
mentioned one time all the way back in
season two it might end there in the
books but in the show
Winterfell makes the most sense the
night king is coming for bran stark
because he is the last grain seer and he
may be coming to kill the Dragons also
those are the night Kings two biggest
threats and guess what bran stark and
the Dragons will both be in Winterfell
during season eight I have laid out my
theory in a few different videos so I
will spare you all the details again but
I am fairly confident Winterfell will be
where the true king of winter falls so I
have to disagree with most of this
episode but keep in mind it's just my
opinion and I could be wrong this league
also said Jon rides regal I want to talk
about this because a photo was released
on reddit that showed what looked to be
Jon Snow riding the green-screen
mechanical dragon unfortunately that
photo is fake I made a video about that
photo a few days ago and the person who
created the photo reached out to me
after I made the video and he said he
was the one that made the photo he said
he did it mean for it to blow up on the
internet like it did but I find that a
little hard to believe why else would
you make that photo and post it on the
internet unless you wanted people to see
it and talk
but he did send me a gift that showed me
how his photo was made so it's
definitely fake and what that being said
there is no evidence of John riding a
dragon next season this is a very
popular theory and John does have the
blood of the Dragon so it's possible not
to mention Rhaegar was named after
John's father so it wouldn't make sense
for John to ride him but it's not enough
to confirm this part of the leak I would
like to see John Rodrigo and face off
against the night king in the sky and I
felt like they were setting this up by
having John bond with drogon but we have
to wait and see if any other information
comes out this is also the same time
Bryan supposedly breaks the news to John
about his parents I know this will
happen next season but I can't say what
episode it will happen in I don't think
it'll be an episode 1 or 2 because they
usually drag these kind of things out
they usually make us wait as long as
possible for the big reveal so I am
expecting it to happen midseason or at
the end of the season John does need to
know the truth and if this series would
end without John finding out I would be
very disappointed because I feel like
John needs this closure in his life and
Who am I kidding
I need this closure too I want John to
know the truth about who he truly is
but now let's move on to some more of
the bigger revelations from this leaked
episode according to the leaked gillies
baby is what the night king is coming
for because it says gillies baby has the
blood of the Dragon as well in the night
Kane needs babies to turn into White
Walkers but little Sam was gonna be the
100th sacrifice which would mean he was
meant to be the next night King I
personally do not think it'll go down
like this for various reasons the main
reason is because it says Melisandre
wants to burn Gilley's baby because she
has seen all of these things in the
flames the only problem is Melisandre
already had several opportunities to do
this but she never mentioned it until
now Melisandre was at the wall the same
time Gilly and her baby were there but
there was no indication that she had any
interest in this child now in the books
jon is worried about Melisandre possibly
burning mance rayder's son so he
switches babies with Gilly but they
never did any of this in the show also
if this baby was meant to be the next
night king why didn't the night king
take this more serious when he sent the
white Walker to get
the baby from Gillian Sam if the night
king knew this baby was gonna be that
important
why would he only send one man after him
he should have sent an entire force to
get this baby or at the very least once
the white Walker didn't return with the
baby you would think this would be an
act of war against the night king and he
would have reacted by trying to keep
them from getting little Sam on the
other side of the wall but instead they
were able to make it safely to the wall
in cross without having any more of the
others hot on their trail I just think
if the night King needed this particular
baby so bad he would have tried a hell
of a lot harder to get him but let's
argue for the other side now there is a
good chance gillies baby does have
special blood there has to be a good
reason why the night King chose crashed
her sons in the first place the night
king could have taken babies from the
wildlings if he wanted to but for some
reason he only wanted Craster's which
makes me think there has to be something
special about them I don't know if they
have Targaryen blood or not but my
friend Tony made a very interesting
theory about this many years ago Tony
has a channel called Teflon TV and he
made the first video that I know about
that proposed the idea that Craster is
Bloodraven son I would highly recommend
watching that video if you want to know
more about this because it was really
well done another reason why this could
be true is because of the third big
twist as we all know the showrunner said
there would be three big ones over the
course of his show and there was already
two the first twist was with princess
shereen's death and the second twist was
with her doors name reveal and death so
there is one more big twist coming next
season now when you look at what
happened to Shireen and Hodor what do
they have in common with Gilly son all
three of them are completely innocent
characters princess Shireen and Hodor
were two of the very few characters in
this story who were purely innocent just
like Gilly son
Craster might have been a piece of [ __ ]
but that is a little Sam's fault he
didn't get to choose who his father was
so maybe the third big twist has
something to do with another innocent
character I don't know how likely that
is but I just wanted to throw that idea
out there
I highly doubt the night king is coming
for her son because of the other reasons
I just gave but like most things in this
story I guess anything is possible
now let's move on to John stabbing
Melisandre in the chest this part of the
leek really intrigued me because I made
a video months ago where I said I
believe Melisandre is nice and Nisa and
I listed many reasons why I think
Melisandre makes a hell of a lot more
sense being nice Anissa than Daenerys I
still stand by that theory today and I
actually have been wanting to update
that video because I found twice as much
evidence in the books that I feel pointa
Melisandre this is one theory that I
made that I'm very confident in coming
true however I'm not so sure they will
do this in the television show I know I
have made a few videos talking about
Nissa Nissa but I've always said I don't
fully believe the show will go in this
direction but if they do it will be
Melisandre I actually made my video
several months before this leak even hit
read it but since this leak was saying
Melisandre was nice Aneesa it really
intrigued me for purely bias reasons
because I feel the same way I know there
is a strong case for Daenerys but she
wouldn't be my first choice although
everyone believes I want Daenerys to die
for some reason which couldn't be any
further from the truth but anyways I
just don't see it playing out like this
I don't think they will go to the
Trident
I don't think Melisandre will try to
burn Gilly son and I don't think that
would be the main factor for jon
plunging hearts vein into her chest I
did love the idea about Melisandre is
Ruby being the thing that caused a sword
to go red I thought that was a very
interesting idea but overall I feel like
this is where the plot leak
really started to go off the rails I
can't prove that this episode is fake
but based on my opinions it seems very
unlikely to happen exactly like this
however whenever I think a leak sounds
ridiculous I always go back to the
season 7 leak because I remember the
white capture mission beyond the wall
sounded ridiculous but it ended up being
100% true so who really knows what kind
of crazy [ __ ] they come up with the next
season now there is some evidence of
Melisandre being involved in the Great
War everyone knows she said she was
coming back to Westeros but she may have
been spotted on set during all those
filming in the north with the army of
the Dead it's very hard to make out in
the photo but people are saying
Melisandre is there amongst all the
other soldiers but it isn't clear enough
to make a confirmation all right now all
of this leads me to the showdown
the night came and I have to say this
was very underwhelming plot leaks
usually leave out tons of details but
John's sword fight against the night
King seemed very brief to say the least
I think they both swung their swords a
total of four times and I hope it isn't
that quick they have been building this
tension between these two characters for
multiple seasons now and the night King
is supposed to be this badass so he
can't go out that fast I do agree that
it will win with a sword fight between
these two and I think John will win but
not like this
there is really no way for me to prove
or disprove anything though because this
leak was very specific with each scene
it had all these small details that
leaks usually don't provide there have
been photos and videos leaking lately
but there isn't any real context to
what's happening in them sometimes we do
get a glimpse of characters on this set
and sometimes reports come out that say
some characters are on set filming
battle scenes but the photos are taken
from so far away it's too hard to make
out exactly what's happening at the end
of the day this leaked episode could
still be true I haven't seen anything
yet that tells me these locations are
going to be used so there is still a
chance that all of this is right but in
my opinion I would say no way we should
get a very good idea of where the Great
War will end very soon the big King's
Landing set they had been building is
complete and filming is about to begin
if there is any sign of the knight king
or the army of the Dead being at this
set then we should know how far south
the knight King will actually make it
but I don't think he gets that far the
knight King in his army needs to be
stopped as soon as possible they can't
allow him to grow his army any larger
than it already is or else everyone is
screwed Daenerys can't lose any more
dragons to the night King or else they
are screwed I think it needs to end
where it all started and that's in
Winterfell but let me know what you
think where do you believe the war will
end do you think gillies baby is that
important to the knight King and do you
think there will be a nice Anisa these
are some very hot debates right now so
put your thoughts down below I want to
thank you all for stopping by and
continuing to support the channel and I
also want to thank all of my supporters
on patreon you've really helped me make
strides on YouTube and I can't thank you
enough
have a great day everyone I'll see you
soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]